كثفت القيود على البنوك التركيه
واتخذت اجراءات احترازيه تحسبا لاي انخفاض
في قيمه الليره بعد انتخابات الرابع عشر
من مايو عده قرارات من المركزي التركي
للبنوك نصت على الحد من بيع الدولارات
للشركات التي ليست بحاجه ملحه لسداد
مستحقاتها مقابل منح الاولويه لاصحاب
الودائع بالليره ضمن النظام الادخار
الذي تبلغ قيمته حاليا 100 مليار دولار
هذا النظام اطلق عام 2021 عندما شهدت
الليره التركيه ازمه وارتفع التضخم لاعلى
مستوى في 24 عاما بسبب سياسه اردوغان
الاقتصاديه غير التقليديه فهي شديده
التيسير مقابل تضخم مرتفع بلغ الشهر
الماضي 44%
قواعد مصرفيه اخرى لرفع نسبه ودائع البنوك
بالليره الى 65% خلال النصف الاول من
العام الحالي فاذا قلت عن نسبه 60% فعلى
البنوك ايداع جزء اكبر من الودائع
بالعملات الاجنبيه لدى المركزي وشراء سبعه
في المئه اضافيه من السندات الحكوميه
بالعمله المحليه اما اذا زادت تلك النسبه
فستعفى البنوك من الاحتفاظ ببعض السندات
الحكوميه بالعمله المحليه ومن جانبها
ترستاندرد ان تلك القواعد ستؤثر على
الارباح السنويه لمقرضي تركيا وتتعثر ثقه
المستثمرين فيما لا يزال القلق مسيطرا على
حركه العمله فكل من وكاله فيتش و جولدن
ساتس
توقعوا ان تشهد اللير مزيدا من الضغوط بعد
الانتخابات وتتعرض اسهم البنوك لتقلبات
حاده اذا ما اتخذت السياسه الماليه شكلا
جديدا ما يؤدي الى انكماش القطع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات